identity and what a feminine traits and
what uh considered too masculine for a
female to to kind of be I think for me
what are the traits the femininity
Community is so interesting to me I was
going on Iran on Twitter about this
because they're just so they're so broad
they just say like a lot of nothing in
different ways
um when I when I think of femininity I
think of like nurturing I think of like
typical like motherly traits
um however I've found that there's no
real way to like measure it or show
anything or show any work or really so I
don't know it's so broad that's why it
really confuses me is that that's that
Community I'm interested because I think
sometimes I can be seen as being in my
masculine energy because why why would
you say that for a while I was a single
mother and I was doing everything by
myself and I was very much used to okay
this is down to me I'm gonna do this by
myself everyone's relying on me I can
get on with it you're not a single
mother anymore okay okay you're married
um I'm not married but I have a partner
yeah so I was very kind of used to doing
everything on my own that's me I've got
this kind of thing and some some people
and some men would consider that too
masculine so I'm just interested
is it okay yeah I looked it up I was
just I saw this chart when I was going
on my rant on Twitter that I tweeted so
I was trying to find it
um feminine not aggressive dependent
easily influenced um submissive passive
home oriented easily hurt emotionally
indecisive talkative gentle sensitive to
others feelings very desirous of
security cries a lot emotional verbal
kind nurturing tactful another chart
says intuitive generous nurturing
creative collaborative caring receptive
grateful which I agree with those I
agree with those statements but like
when you said that um for me when I had
my son was when
my level of femininity had to come out
awesome that's interesting because you
just said that when you had your
children your masculinity came out yeah
because I felt like I had to be I was a
single one before that but I had a girl
so my first daughter my first child was
a girl but when I had my son like my son
is very very affectionate very very he
he just brought out that side of me that
needed to nurture him in a way and also
I didn't want him to
grow up thinking that men women are in
their masculine they're angry like I
wanted him to see the calmness and the
Stillness and for him to be able to
communicate with me openly because it's
not taught to young men that you can
communicate you could like if he's upset
I don't go in shouting at him I don't
shout I don't raise my like I very much
bring the femininity to my son all the
time I have a question
um all right so you're not in a
relationship you know
so no
are you sure
it's Alex I mean there might be a
relationship soon maybe there's a guy
you like yeah okay okay okay and then
you're in a relationship no no you're
not you're in a relationship would you
guys
um if you guys were to marry the person
you're talking to or talking to in a
relationship with would you quit your
job if you told you to
no questions asked
if if I'm married if I've married him if
I if I if I'm married if I've married
him it means I trust him to lead and I
would trust his decision in that and I
would trust that it's for the best
interest of our family okay yeah you
would yeah so if he said to me oh sorry
go ahead so if he said to me you know I
I think you should you quite work and
I'd be like yeah again I trust him in
that and I'm ready for that because I
feel like he's allowed me to step into
that feminine energy and I don't I no
longer have to be like right I need to
be on it I need to do this I need to do
that on my I'm on my own I'm not on my
own anymore I can trust him lean into
him and yeah so I would I'd love that
actually what about you same I would
really love that I think I would be like
I'm really ready to settle down now like
I would think about kids so I think yeah
like if he is in control and if he's
leading this whole marriage then I would
say
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because I feel like he must have
worked something out
I think the difference between Western
women and women from abroad
the subject
from abroad
would probably be more submissive and
not question as much and I think I don't
know I want to ask the guys here right
do you think that the women
from the west or women abroad would make
better wives for you guys
you know what ah for starters
I haven't had problems getting
submissive women in the UK
but
um I think I'd say 50 of the
people have been in long-term
relationships with have been
even if they live in the UK they've
they've had their formative years in
another country right and
very I'm not going to say submissive I'm
going to say very feminine like um I've
heard people say you know we both have
masculine and feminine energy in us but
all the women I've been with I can't
even imagine them being supremely
masculine at all like they're so
feminine that even when they're trying
to do masculine type things it just
comes off feminine and that's femininity
asking like what countries they were
from respectively
um the one I'm really thinking about now
she was based uh she was brought up in
South Africa okay and another one I'm
thinking of she was like hot she was
rich her mom's Filipino so right you
know
um and a Filipino that wasn't born here
yeah right so she's got that influence
yeah I think I think ultimately women in
the west are brought up to be more
independent whereas women in different
cultures may be brought to be
independent But ultimately are brought
up to serve the man so based on that
they're wired differently and they have
different goals into or they have they
play different roles in comparison to
women in the west when it comes to
marriages and relationships so it's just
yeah this is what it is basically yeah
and also I just want to piggyback off
that and say
um
I think a lot of women in the west they
look at it as it's almost like a job
that they they kind of have to do to
look after a man whereas other women
raising other parts of the world
they look at it like they want to do
this right yeah and I find whenever I've
um been with a woman long term or just
even dated them short term they all seem
to want to do feminine things for me
like you know they want to do my hair
they want to cook for me I've never had
to ask a woman to cook for me
I mean it might be something about my
energy as well I don't know but I think
that factors into it as well yeah yeah
well that that brings me to another
Point um you know the guy on the clip
that we can't show yeah
um you know he said he did well over
here uh but it's just that in Russia he
went to Russia because there's more
there's just more of what he wants and I
really don't see a problem with that by
the way you know if you think that
you're gonna have more options more of
what you like in a certain country why
why wouldn't you go but from what I've
seen is that there's a lot of women
because they called the possible Bros
shout out to the possible Bros
shout out to the passport Bros
um there's a lot of women in the west
now trying to shame passport Bros men
who are actually going on the cliff I
know yeah yeah and they they look like
bullies going up I think it's a delivery
I don't necessarily think because you
can have a choice and a preference of
whatever you want I think it's a
delivery of shaming another type of
woman just because you like something
else it's like the oh I like this
because this person you you're prefer if
that's your preference you like women
from Russia then say that and say I want
I want to go here but you don't have to
like give the reason is because of just
say you like that I think but I think
the stuff he said was true it was true
yeah and like we we are more overweight
yeah UK they always talk [ __ ] about the
us but y'all ain't been here
your obesity stats are better but not
much because if we follow America we're
like little puppies after America and
that's the thing like when we are less
submissive in the west the women and the
women
um outside of here were raised more to
be wives right and like instead of
instead of shaming men for like saying
what's true I think we should say you
know maybe we should try to learn from
them as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible